Seth: Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden toured Hurricane
damage today in Florida
and met with
Governor Ron Desantis.
And Desantis has been
working around the clock
to recover from wearing
this outfit.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden tweeted
a picture of himself this week
in a green sports car.
Oh my God, look at him.
[ Laughter ]
He loves his wife,
yet has the energy of a man
who was divorced an hour ago.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ] "Got me a hot young
girlfriend, too. She's 65."
[ Light Laughter ]
Russian President Vladimir Putin
is reportedly planning
to order a nuclear test
near the border of Ukraine
to demonstrate his willingness
to use nuclear weapons.
Oh, you don't have to
prove you're crazy.
You ride horses half naked
and your best friend
is Donald Trump.
We see you.
[ Light laughter ]
According to a new report,
staffers who worked in former
President Trump's White House
were not surprised that in the
raid of his Mar-A-Lago residence
the FBI found
highly-classified materials
mixed in with news clippings
because trump never followed
the strict rules
for handling
sensitive documents.
Also, you're not gonna
believe this,
he never separated his trash
from his recycling.
[ Laughter ]
And in a new animated
"Scooby-Doo" Halloween special,
the character Velma Dinkley
will be depicted as LGBTQ.
Now, you might be thinking,
"What about Fred?"
But hear me out.
[ Laughter ]
Hear me out.
Fred is an overconfident
white guy
who thinks he's a detective
just because he owns a van.
He's definitely straight.
[ Laughter ]
He probably has
an alt-right podcast
where he complains
about Velma being gay.
[ Light laughter ]
New York Yankees star
Aaron Judge last night
hit his 62nd home run
of the season
breaking --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, give it up for Aaron Judge
breaking Roger Maris'
American League record,
And to add insult to injury,
the ball hit a Mets fan
and killed him.
[ Laughter ]
And you know what the Met's fans
last words were?
"At least I don't gotta watch us
blow it in the playoffs."
[ Laughter ]
Al Pacino is reportedly closing
a deal with a publisher
to write a book.
It will be the first
autobiography
written in all caps.
[ Laughter ]
Very, very unfair photo.
[ Light laughter ]
But that is his writing face.
According to new reports, prices
for real Christmas trees
are expected to increase
this year,
so expect some changes to
Rockefeller Plaza this December.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according to
a new survey,
60% of Americans said they have
never cheated on a partner
in a relationship,
and if you have to ask,
"Does it count if --"
the answer is yes.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.